convicted murderer brandon bernard was
put to death by
lethal injection last night it was the
first execution in 130 years
at a federal prison during a
presidential lame-duck period
the 40-year-old was executed despite the
pleas of celebrities politicians
and jurors in his case errol barnett has
the story
uttering his final words last night
toward relatives of the victims he
played a role in killing
brandon bernard said i'm sorry becoming
the ninth federal death row inmate to be
executed this year
bernard was 18 when he and four other
teenagers abducted youth ministers
todd and stacy badly a fellow gang
member shot the bagleys in the head
bernard then lit the couple's car on
fire with both still inside
in 2000 a jury sentenced bernard to
death
the shooter and bernard's co-defendant
christopher villalva
was executed in september mr bernard
said
you know i i try every day to make up
a little bit i know it'll never make up
for what i did
but i'm trying to add some good to the
world
bernard's lawyer telling cbs news last
week he was a reformed man
he also says they were mitigating
circumstances and that bernard was
neither the shooter
nor the ringleader of the attack but
experts were
split on whether stacy bagley was killed
from the gunshot
or if she died from smoke inhalation
five jurors and a prosecutor on
bernard's case
pled for mercy before his death our
david becknote spoke with one of them
earlier this month
i've always struggled i guess especially
at that time in my life i'm standing on
my convictions
and i regret that now the death penalty
is far too harsh for the his level of
involvement
in this crime on the day of bernard's
scheduled execution the supreme court
denied his request for a stay
president trump did not grant his
petition for clemency
my whole journey with criminal justice
reform
started about a year ago when i came to
see the president one of bernard's
fiercest advocates
reality star kim kardashian west tweeted
quote i'm so messed up
they killed brandon he was such a
reformed person
he is sorry so sorry for the hurt and
pain
he has caused others in a statement late
last night the victim's family
thanked the doj and president trump for
giving them
the closure they needed after 21 years
the administration plans to execute four
more prisoners
before inauguration day errol barnett
for cbs this morning
new york all right errol thank you very
much these are the first
executions in about 17 years at the
federal level so it's a change